- So it's possible that a
lot of President Trump's
late term pardons might not actually
shield the people that he pardoned.
We know that the Trump administration
was perfectly capable of writing
the broadest possible pardons.
For example, with Michael Flynn,
he received a pardon on
"any and all possible crimes
arising out of the facts,"
for which he was charged.
You rarely see pardons like that.
It hearkens back to Gerald
Ford pardoning Richard Nixon.
It's extremely rare, but
they know how to do it.
The thing is, the Trump administration
barely followed any procedure whatsoever,
so it's not surprising
that some of these pardons
might be defective,
like the pardons against
Bannon, Manafort, Stone, Papadopoulos.
These might actually not
provide any protection
for these reprobates.
All of these pardons were
drawn incredibly narrowly,
and prosecutors might be
able to charge other crimes.
I'll explain why in part two.